knowledge is power the more you know the
better informed your decision can be
libraries in that respect play an
incredibly important role in our
democracy the New York Public Library
for instance has an amazing collection
of Arctic materials materials about
explorers who went to the Arctic lost
their lives they're an extraordinary
collection of maps of the Arctic some
accurate some inaccurate and I think
libraries in that way bringing together
researchers scientists artists
sociologists psychologists people from
all walks of life can have a very
important role in better understanding
the kind of predicament we find
ourselves in today with everything
that's going on in the world today with
various political struggles we might
encounter having to do with climate
change or climate control with people
denying the fact that the world maybe is
warming up libraries can in some way be
the spokesperson as an institution they
merely can become the place the hub the
place where people congregate around
ideas and learn what the data is learn
what the challenges are and make better
informed decisions of how the world is
changing and make those decisions based
on a better acquaintance with what the
knowledge of the past is and how the
past will inform the future
you